today we're reviewing the amd
rx 6900 xt sort of flagship card the
6800 xt
and the 3080 are more the proper gaming
flagships
and then you've got the halo effects
products the 6900xt
and the 3090 from nvidia so we're
reviewing the 6900xt it comes in about
under the 39d there's some key
differences but and the
thus far at least seems to be targeting
at 6900xt more
fully towards gaming and that's what
we'll be looking at today alongside
power overclocking very interesting
behaviors there especially with
undervolting
and some thermal and fan performance
before that this video is brought to you
by arctic cooling and its liquid freezer
2 line
arctic is actively restocking its liquid
freezer 2 coolers that rank among the
top performers for cpu coolers right now
including on ryzen cpus the liquid
freezer 2 series is focused on high
throttle performance and value
featuring a blackout design and
including a vrm fan mounted on top of
the pump block
to help provide airflow over neighboring
vrm heatsinks
arctic has also started selling its p12
120 case fans
learn more at the links in the
description below so getting into this
one then the architecture hasn't changed
from the 6800xe all the behaviors are
pretty much the same as we've plotted in
those reviews
so that stuff still all applies the fan
behavior is applied
because it's actually the same cooler
too except for pcb changes
on the vrm side and then the
thermal response changes for frequency
apply as well so our overclocking stream
with the 6800xds where we show some of
that
thermal frequency response that applies
to 6900 xt
the card also has the same memory it's
at 16 gigabytes of memory on the 6900xt
the key difference between the 30 90 and
the 6900
is that memory capacity so the 3090
is still a 24 gigabyte frame buffer we
have all scene rumors at this point of
refreshes for the 3080 but
they haven't materialized yet so for now
the 3090
is the only car that sits above amd's
cards for
memory capacity in the current gaming
like geforce lineup from nvidia
that 24 gigabytes it's enough to be a
consideration for maybe 3d artists
people who don't need
the quadro level validation and
assurances
or the titan level features but could
still use the memory so 3d art
for example andrew coleman on our team
can make use of it
in blender and sculpting applications
like that but otherwise
amd has been advertising the 6900xd as
roughly at parity
or plus or minus a little bit from the
3090 in rasterization performance not
uh speaking of ray tracing there and
at 500 cheaper that's a significant
thing to claim so we'll be looking at
those numbers the amd performance thus
far as a recap for the 6800 and xt
versions of the card
has uh an interesting behavior where at
1080p
and 1440p but especially 1080 you start
to see the scale
shift where if nvidia has a slight or
even
sometimes up to 15 20 lead in some
instances at 4k
as you approach 1080 amd will start
taking the lead
so we'll be looking at that again today
as well and obviously this gets into
territory where
you as a user have to be aware of your
own use cases
and what you want in order to extract
the most valuable information from
reviews
as always you should watch multiple
reviews to put the whole thing together
because these things are getting
extremely complex and the test matrices
are ballooning to a point where
it's impossible for anyone to test
absolutely everything and that gets
especially true with ray tracing for
testing today as well
where you now have considerations of
dlss on or off so you're running
everything twice for that
and even the game selection is becoming
challenging too
so we're gonna get into the review today
this is
a video card that will supposedly exist
at some point
we don't know what the stock's going to
be presumably not great because it's a
high-end card so yields are
are going to be more restricted for
these and push down to the lower tiers
and this might be something that you
can leverage later rather than
immediately for your buying decisions as
a quick reminder
the news video we recently published uh
again i don't really particularly
want to share the information but uh i
will be in for
a minor surgery not a big deal on the
day this review goes up only reason i'm
mentioning that is because review
publishing
is uh it's always pretty high stress
because there's
follow-ups where people start
discovering things and they want
reviewers to follow up on those so
we will not be able to do that this
particular week if there's some
interesting story that emerges from the
6900xt i would encourage you to check
out any of the
uh high number of other good reviewers
out there for their follow-ups because
we're going to be
unable to do so for the 6900xe this
particular week all right enough of that
let's get into the review
starting with the frequency numbers
we'll start with frequency validation to
ensure that the card is working as
expected but also to learn how it
compares to the amd rx 6800 xd
previously
this plot is zoomed into a vertical axis
range of just 250 megahertz
from 2250 to 2500 megahertz and that's
in order to better see the data
that said it does make the gaps look
much wider than they sometimes are
this is by design for legibility but
just remember that a proper zero scale
would show how closely some of the
entries are
that stated starting again with the
6800xt card from previously the plot pin
pond around somewhere between 2330 and
2360 megahertz
with an initial spike at the outset that
was not sustainable as the power load
and thermals ramped
the cards as always will run into power
and thermal constraints for frequency
boosting
before anything else plotting the rx
that one held closer to 22.75 to 22.90
megahertz
running lower than the 6800 xt when both
were stock
the xt our new one peaked at 23.75
megahertz to start
then fell to about 2289 to 2310
megahertz
once steady-state thermals were achieved
that puts the 6900xt stock card as
technically below the 6800 xt
and above the 6800 stock card for
frequency
on average it was about 50 megahertz
below the 68 xt but it fluctuated
and the additional cus will make up for
this loss the next chart will show fan
curve responding to the temperature ramp
this can sometimes be helpful for
identifying fan curves that are too
initially aggressive or
too anemic as was the case for some of
nvidia's launches this year
with its fe coolers it's also useful
just for understanding the v
bios temperature targets the temperature
that the card tries to maintain when
left to auto
the 6800 xt as a reminder held about
1600 rpm under auto conditions in our
test environment
which kept the gpu edge temperature to
about 75 degrees celsius
and the junction temperature in a range
of 93 to 95. plotting the new 6900xt
the autofan curve planted the fans lower
at just 300 rpm
the gv temperature is meanwhile plotted
at 80 degrees celsius for edge
and about 93 to 95 for junction we
already know that amd's v
bios behaviors including core frequency
and fan rpm
follow junction rather than edge as this
is the case it seems that the delta
between junction and edge on this
particular cooler mount
using the same cooler as the 6800xt just
may be mounted better
is better than on our 6800 xd it's
reduced the gap
is smaller here further helpful is the
fact that the 6900 xt is a better bin
than the 6800 xt words from amd itself
and so is capable of running at lower
voltages for a given frequency
than the 6800 xt these two factors
combined
allow a lower junction temperature thus
allowing the fans to spin slower
in order to maintain the temperature
target if we were to manually adjust the
fan to equal the 6800 6800xt reference
card's auto speeds the 6900xt would run
more efficiently overall
again that's part quality of the mount
and part bin
noise levels haven't changed from the
6800xc cooler so
we can show the same chart the 6900xt
ended up in the range of about 36.1 dba
when allowed to run under auto v
bios conditions and tested with our
standardized methodology
that's with a 20 inch distance from the
cooler the 6800 xt
was closer to 40 dba stock under these
auto conditions
for gaming workloads at least and the
reason for the difference is described
in the previous chart
maximum noise level is about 57 dba but
this shouldn't be encountered unless
there's something wrong with the mount
like if you reassembled it improperly or
if you manually set the max speed as
another reason so overclocking works
in amd software by setting a clock range
that allows a
minimum min to max delta of 100
megahertz that's the closest you can get
the two together
amd limits the gb frequency and its
setting to
3000 megahertz in software for the 6900
xt though you shouldn't expect to hit
that and it limits the memory frequency
to 2150 megahertz and software
unfortunately this is a huge limitation
for extreme overclocking so
uh it does limit what we can do on ln2
but for air overclocking
the memory limitation is the biggest one
for you on this car the problem is that
changing the frequency only nets a
reduction in performance on the 6900xt
in our experience
but it's in a way which will cause a lot
of users based on past experience
browsing forums
to think that they have a stable high
clock of something insane like 3 000
megahertz
when it's actually running way lower so
just a psa to be careful to validate
your clocks
when you think you've set them higher
the range here will apply and the
drivers won't crash but the performance
can silently tank in the background
in this overclock stepping chart you can
see that our initial stock performance
had us in the range of 22
20 to 20 to 80 megahertz the temperature
numbers are
useful only for comparing the frequency
but shouldn't really be
read into beyond that because it's all
spot checking here so
the power increase of 15 in one of the
earlier rows
bumped us to 23 26 22 98 megahertz
and as we run through the numbers you
can see in rows 31 to 36 we tried
everything
up to 26 20 to 27 20 megahertz for the
range
but we were seeing either the same
clocks or reduced clocks sometimes
in the far right you can see our port
royal score not run for everything but
for a good amount of them
and we used port royal because it's
highly consistent where you'll often get
the same exact score run to run if you
change nothing or plus or minus just a
couple of points so
very useful for this the 25 90 the 2690
range was perfectly stable and looked
fine
but plotted at 87.02 points to the stock
runs at
that's a major regression and is again
proof of why you should be validating
the overclocks
with performance to make sure it's not
getting worse silently we slowly dialed
in an optimal range of 2450 to 25 50
megahertz for core
which got us to 10 246 points this held
consistently and plotted an improvement
in every test pass whereas other
settings
like 2480 to 2580 or 2500 to 2600
would occasionally bug out and regress
but they would also occasionally plot
high
from memory 2150 was fine and that's the
max setting amd allows
ultimately these frequency range numbers
don't really seem to mean anything
because
it just ignores them as soon as it
becomes unstable which is
bad it should crash instead because if
it's ignoring them
then you don't really know what's going
on anymore as a user and you're not
really sure that anything's working or
you leave it thinking that it worked
and you don't actually have a stable oc
the end uplift was 8.3
versus stock but the important thing
here is that we had to reduce the
voltage on this particular card
to get any uplift in fact if you look at
some of the scoring we're
not sure if we plotted it in this chart
but where we basically restored the
stock except we reduced
the voltage then we started seeing
uplift so
uh 1175 is the default but we brought it
all the way down to like 1050 1080 1020
all in that range
millivolts and we were seeing uplifts
for most of those until we hit
instability in like the 10 30 10 20
range we're gonna keep the sam numbers
really short since we already explained
it the 6800 xt review this is just for a
couple of a b comparisons as a reminder
we don't have the 30 90 in here right
now but at 500 more it's not really
direct comparison anyway
and it'll be in the next dozen or more
charts in tomb raider at 4k and alien
sam saw almost no difference on the 6900
xt
it went from 97 to 101 fps average so
that's enough to create a few more
percentage points of space
against the 3080 but that's about it at
1080p the 6900xt with sam off equals the
6800 xt with sam on but we're also up
against a cpu limit here
which constrains the chart the fps on
versus
off difference is still just a couple of
points so no big deal
hitman 2 had the biggest impact from sam
previously so we'll show that as a
contrast to the near zero results
in tomb raider in this one the 4k ultra
result had the 6800 xt previously
scaling from 100 fps average to 111.
the 6900xt with sam on moves to 119 so
that gives it an average of 18 lead
over the rtx 3080 in this very specific
test three kingdoms showed no difference
sam on versus off had it about 46 fps
average either way
still below the 3080 with sam off one at
4k and still the same frame time
consistency advantage over the 3080
that you'll see in the later charts so
that's enough of these we have the rest
of the sam data in the 6800xt review
and you can check that out for more
scaling information let's move into
rasterized game performance on our
standard test bench this will be one of
our last few reviews on new silicon
where we'll be using this bench we'll
probably be moving to zen 3 or to rocket
lake in early 2021
depending on which one does better for a
gpu test platform
might be a while longer for rocket lake
though either way for now we're sticking
with what we have
to finish up the year starting with
shadow of the tomb raider at 4k
the rx 6900 xt stock gpu ran at 98 fps
average with lows paced behind as
expected
this puts it about 5 ahead of the 6800xc
stock card with the 6800 xt oc
mostly leveling them the lows are spaced
proportionately on each card and not
significantly different or at least not
noticeably so
the 6900x toc improves to 102 fps
average
with an overclock that is and with an
undervolt and that's a four percent bump
in average frame rate
as for the rtx 3090 that runs 104 fps
average
we didn't have feoc data and our card is
currently disassembled but a more
expensive partner model noting again
that it is
more expensive gained six and a half
percent over the 30 90 fe when using the
original
lower power limit v bios on the ftw3 not
the newer one so then the fe 3090 leads
the reference 6900xt
both stock fittingly by 6.9 percent here
we'll need to remember this number as we
get into the lower resolutions for
testing the scaling as for the rest well
it's the same story as the 3090 was to
the 3080
the 6900xt thus far appears difficult to
justify over andy's
own lower tier sku just like the 3090
was to the 3080.
it's a halo product in the truest sense
of the work at 1440p the rx 6900xt stock
card pulled 172 fps average
approaching the cpu ceiling of about 180
185 for this game
the 6900xt has a 4.7 lead
over the 6800xt stock card and is
functionally tied
with the 6800xtoc the rtx 39dfe is
roughly tied or slightly led by the rx
6900xt which is
one and a half percent ahead on average
fps overclocking both of them puts the
6900 xt at 175 fps average
a bump of 1.8 percent over its original
score
and the 3090 ftw three to 176.
they're about the same either stock or
overclocked at 1440p
there's actually still a bit of
performance scaling at 1080p the rx
6900xt
stock car did 185fps average maintaining
a one and a half percent lead over the
6800 xt
that said we're at a point where there
may be additional headroom obfuscated by
the nature of 1080p's reduced gpu
workload
we'll be able to counter that with ultra
settings in total war shortly
and that's exactly why we run total war
on such abusively high settings
the rtx 3090 fe which allegedly exists
for allegedly 700
runs at 182 fps average that means it
achieves 98 percent of the performance
of the 6900xt stock card
for 300 allegedly three hundred dollars
or less
or two thousand dollars more depending
on where you buy it let's highlight that
6900x toc results separately though
the result was a performance regression
here which is what we warned about
earlier
the performance was scaling at higher
resolutions but here we encountered
clock issues
that would need to be rectified by
either increasing the voltage or
reducing the frequency range
the latter of these is much harder to
work with in that
it barely works at all in the software
as always you won't really know how
stable your overclock
is until you try a variety of different
games and settings and it's likely that
as new games come out you may need to
adjust those settings
due to review timelines we can't rerun
every single test to see if it's stable
in every single resolution of every
single game so we just mark
it when it's not ideal like here it's
easier to just point out the reality
anyway and
it helps to illustrate what you're
looking for in terms of performance
regression
with settings that seem like they're
stable otherwise we need to run the 39d
on this one at a later date we skipped
some benchmarks previously
due to the review timing and the
resolutions total war 3 kingdoms should
be an interesting one for scaling in
this game we run high settings so
they're high enough that there's clean
scaling across all three resolutions
it's needlessly high if you wanted to
just enjoy the game you could do so at
high or very high settings rather than
ultra but ultra is useful for gpu
benchmarking and differentiation
at 4k ultra the 6900xt runs 45 ps
average
out doing the 6800 xt by about point six
percent
improvement with an oc is about five
point three percent and it's a clean
improvement too
no weird stability issues so far we're
three for four in oc scaling without
regression
the rtx 390 fe ran 54.3 fps average here
which
is actually a massive lead over the 6900
xt
of 19.9 percent the rtx 3080 fe
also holds a three and a half percent
lead over the 6900 xt here
showing that the 6900xt seems unhappy
with his combination of settings
game and resolution amd has an advantage
in frame time consistency here
but we wouldn't say that it necessarily
justifies the extra cost
of the 6900xe over one of the lower tier
cards
just like we wouldn't say the bump to a
30 90 an average fps for this one
is justified over cards lower than its
cost at 1440p the 6900xt stock runs
94fps average allowing the oc an
improvement of 4.9 percent
the rx-6900xt now manages to crawl ahead
of the 3080 and average fps
but primarily on a technicality in
theory though this gap should widen as
the resolution lowers again
the 6900xt outperforms the 6800xt by 6.3
percent
but the 6800x doc passes the 6900xt
stock result
as for nvidia's rtx 3090 that plots at
107 fps average
a 14 lead over the rx 6900xc stock
numbers
that's diminished from the 20 lead as a
reminder at 4k
but it's still elite the frame time
consistency scaling
the issues from previously almost
completely vanish here now out of range
of whatever issue was cropping up in 4k
on the nvidia devices
and scaling gives favor overall to
nvidia that said
andy is closing the gap the 3080 feoc
proved to have worse consistency and 0.1
lows due to errant frame times that the
stock results sometimes produced but 24
use obviously demands more tuning for an
oc anyway this game will offer some of
the most useful insight to scaling since
the graphics settings are demanding
enough to largely eliminate the cpu from
the scenario
the 6900xt stock at 1080p ran 147 fps
average which positions the rtx 390 fe
in a lead of 7.6 percent
as a reminder at 4k it was 19.9
then 14 at 1440p and now again
7.6 at 1080p red dead redemption 2 is
next first at 4k we've previously shown
vulkan results with amd cards as well
which you can check in the 6800 and 6800
xt reviews
for this one the rx 6900xt stock card
ran at 84fps average
which has it 11 ahead of the xt
stockguard 75ps average result
that's a more meaningful gain than in
some of the previous tests
the 6900xtoc gained marginally here at
86 fps
average but it remains overall not
particularly worthwhile
unless you just enjoy the process of
overclocking compared to the rtx 3080 fe
card the 6900xt
runs about 1 to 2fps average below it
with one percent
and 0.1 lows that aren't different in
any noticeable ways
they're roughly the same here in other
words with the 3080 technically leading
in our tests and also being technically
cheaper
the rtx 3090 sits at 92 fps average
leading the 3080 by 8.5 percent and the
6900 xt by 10
now on to 1440p previously the 6900xt
led the 6800xt by 11
but at 1440p that widens to 16 the
6800xt gets
close to the 6900 xt but not close
enough to totally invalidate it
it's just enough to keep the 6800 xt's
value
better the 6900x coc pushes to the top
of the charts here
at 148 fps average and as for
comparisons to nvidia
the rtx 3080 sits between the 68 xt
stock
and the 69 xt stock allowing the 69 xt
a lead of 13.8 percent the 3090 is 5.7
percent ahead of the
3080 and the 6900 xt is 7.7
ahead of the rtx 3090 fe despite being
behind in the 4k test previously finally
and briefly at 1080p we're really only
testing to understand the scaling
behavior at this
point of the the benchmarks these cards
should more likely be accompanied with a
higher resolution than 1080
but we can still learn from it the
6900xt stock card led the 390 fe by 7.7
percent at 1440p
and was behind at 4k but it leads the
3090 fe
by 14 in this one the lead is widening
as resolution decreases
that doesn't mean either is a
particularly sensible purchase
when compared to the 3080 and the 68 xt
cards
but the flagship battle allows nvidia a
chart topper
at 4k and amd a chart topper at 1080p
and 1440p
although technically both companies are
more positioning their
6800xt and 3080 cards as the true gaming
flagships we'll skip the usual vulcan to
dx12 comparison
as we've shown several times now and the
stronger performance is in dx12
presently so this was its best case
scenario
and if you want to see the scaling where
nvidia is typically a couple percent
ahead amd's typically a couple percent
behind in one
api versus the other you can check our
68 xt review next up is rainbow six
siege which runs comically high frame
rates on these one thousand
and fifteen hundred dollar cards
starting at 4k the amdrx 6900xt stock
card held 168 fps
average with lows at 144 and 138.
the rtx 3080 holds a lead of 6.4 over
the 6900 xt at 4k
while the rtx 3090 fe holds a lead of
20.8 percent
compared to the 6800xt the 6900xt leads
by 8.4 percent
and performance for the 6900xt overall
isn't strong here it's fine but
it's hard to justify why you would buy
it for this anyway same for the 3090.
we had the overclock stability issues
again in this one so we dropped it from
the charts due to time
that said the oc clearly doesn't hugely
influence the data here
judging from the 6800xt stock and oc
entries which we'll highlight as well
at 1440p the rx 6900xt leads the 6800 xt
stock results of 323 fps average by 9.9
percent
widening its gap from 8.4 at 4k
as for the rtx 3090 its lead narrows to
1.2 percent
from 20.8 at 4k a significant reduction
from its previous heights
the rtx 3080 sits between the 6800xc
stock and to see results
giving us an anchor point for more
reasonably priced cars we'll start going
through these a little bit faster you
can pause for more detail as always but
at 1080p the 6900xt becomes the chart
leader
at 453 fps average leading the rtx 390
fe by a couple percent
the 6800x coc encroaches on the 6900 xd
but once again doesn't quite get there
ray tracing performance is next we
currently have a limited set of four
games for this that we chose prior to
the launch of the rtx 30 series
but we'll refresh it in our next gpu
methodology update
in 2021 we do two of those per year so
it's not too far off
the games chosen include shadow of the
tomb raider with
ray trace shadows enabled and this is
where amd stands the best chance versus
nvidia
then we have control with hybrid
rendering we have dlss on and off
benchmarks for most of the rtx cards
we have minecraft with full path tracing
and quake which doesn't work on amd
right now
so it's not on these tests tomb raider
is first amd has the best chance here
because it's still mostly rasterized
just with some rt shadows
which are relatively lightweight
compared to other features
this means that amd can still leverage
part of its rasterization advantages
in shadow of the tomb raider at 4k with
ray tracing the rtx 3090 ran
65 fps average leading the rx 6900xt by
25.4 percent
the rtx 3080 also leads it at 56 fps
average
to 52 so it's not as much of a lead the
6900xt
out does the 6800xt by 7.5
in this benchmark at 1440p the rx 6900xt
maintains a 6.8
lead over the 6800 xt but it's still
beaten by the 3080 and it's heavily
defeated by the rtx 3090.
finally at 1080p the 6900xc is doing
fine in a good enough sense
but remains poor value compared to the
3080. minecraft is going to be about the
worst representation of amd so
keep that in mind also the fact that
minecraft rt is still in beta
will influence these results as the game
ages the 4k
rt results show that it's unplayable
without dlss
where we have an rtx 3080 at 33 fps
or at about 87 fps with dlss as for the
6900 xt
that's at about 15 fps average compared
with 14 and
12 fps for the other amdrx cards this
one just it's not gonna work out since
it's fully path traced
so amd has nothing to gain from its
rasterization pipeline advantages and
because it completely leverages rt
hardware in this game
it's going to be behind there too we
don't have 3090 numbers with dlss off
here and we won't due to the unique
time circumstances and constraints that
i have during this review cycle
but the good news is that they're
irrelevant because you shouldn't be
buying a 3090 for gaming anyway
the 3080 is one that we do have and even
in a like for like scenario with dlss
off it's still heavily advantaged by
over 2x here versus the 6900 xt
at 1440p the amd rx 6900xt ran at 32 fps
average whereas the nvidia rtx 3080
held 130 fps average with dlss on and 68
with the lss off again that's more than
2x the performance of the amd card
in terms of frame rate and even more
with the lss on the lsson is also a
completely valid way to play this title
since the blocky nature of minecraft
makes it easy to predict and
reduces the risk of any meaningful image
quality loss that you might see in
games that aren't the same blocks pasted
over and over finally at 1080p
the 6900xd climbs to 52 fps average
which is
actually playable it's pretty good for
where it was positioned previously
that still marks the 2060 ko with dlss
on
as better or the 3080 without dlss
as 77 percent ahead last up is control
for this one we test with both dlss on
and off for nvidia and we use the only
settings available for amd which would
be dlss off
for nvidia because dlss fakes the
resolution
it's not a true like for like comparison
to
toggle rt on and off but also toggle
dlss with
it so to get the full picture ideally
you do both of those things you have
numbers with dlss
on and off and with rt on and off
to get the full matrix for the testing
so
that said dlss is a valid advantage in
this title
dls2 is actually decent here and it
doesn't make it look like they smeared
vaseline all over the screen
like some other games look as with
minecraft we haven't fully added the
3090 numbers with dlss off
but once again that doesn't actually
matter because you shouldn't buy the 30
90 for this
we'll compare against what we do have
for now at 1080p
the 6900xt ran 73 fps average
which actually isn't bad it's not
competitive but it's not bad and it is
playable the 3070 fe out does this one
by 8.1 percent with dlss
off and that's at 79 fps average or it
has a 62
lead with dlss on at 118 fps average
compared to the 6800 xt the 6900xd
improves the numbers by 3.7
so not that much the 3080 meanwhile ran
at 106 fps average with dlss off
or 137 fps average with dlss on and as a
reminder the 3090 numbers
we only have with dlss on so we can't
make the full comparison and we'll just
skip ahead at 1440p the rx 6900xt stock
gpu did 48 fps average
with lows still paced proportionally
behind
and well overall unfortunately for the
card although it fares much better here
than it did in minecraft
it's not doing as well as it did in
shadow of the tomb raider competitively
with the lighter rt workload
the 6900xt is outmatched by the 3070 fe
with the lss off
running 51 fps average it's similar to
the 3060 ti with dlss off
or the 2060 ko with the lss on at 4k
the 6900xt card did 24.2 fps average
hardly moving the needle versus the 23
fps average
of the 6800 xt that puts the card as
about 7.6
ahead of the rtx 3060 ti with dlss off
mind you
or below the 3070 fe with the lss
disabled
the rtx 3070 ran at 47 fps average
with dlss on and it wasn't until the 30
80 fe with dlss on
that we passed 60 fps average we'll
quickly show power numbers as measured
for total card power draw not counting
system draw
the rx 6900xt stock card pulled about
300 watts and furmark tying it with the
6800 xt and placing it about 20 watts
below the 3080 fe
or 56 below the 30 90 fe the 6900 xt
jumped to 350 watts
when overclocked and undervolted in
three kingdoms at 4k the 6900xt pulled
about the same
300 watts when stock and again about 340
watts when overclocked positioning it
the same hierarchically as infer mark so
that's it for
the data now similar to the 3060 ti
review
we're we're at a point where it's a bit
disillusioning to review review
to review reviews to review video cards
and
know that there's not going to be enough
stock
on launch day the card is supposed to be
launching at the same time as
the review embargo lifts from what we
understand so
if that's the case and you've watched to
this point i'm sorry it's probably out
of stock by now
and that leads us down the 360 ti review
path where we're saying
here's all the numbers figure out how
you feel about it now
ignoring the inventory completely and
sticking too strictly msrp
and assuming availability so this is
where it's maybe more useful in a month
from now
our opinion on the 6900xt is similar to
the 3090. you really shouldn't be buying
it
for gaming in almost any scenario you'd
be better off if you want amd
going with the 6800 xt and if you're
open to either
perhaps going with a 3080 depending on
where the prices shake out for
especially the partner models which are
the ones that are significantly
better in quality of life features than
the reference models from either company
so just like the 3090 the 6900 xt
it's a halo product it benefits
significantly in that amd
unlike nvidia did not try to claim
ridiculous things like being
an 8k 60fps ready gaming card which
was clearly not actually true it was
true for maybe
do maternal which as we said before it
can run on the tamagotchi from the 90s
so they benefit there the marketing
wasn't as
uh just false
but you still should buy one of the
lower tier cars so we would consider the
3080 and the 6800xd to be the
sort of true flagships for gaming and
those are the ones we'd push you to
if you're trying to buy a flagship if
you have too much money
then sure maybe a 6900 xt would get you
quote
just the best especially in scenarios
like 1080p 1440p
and then nvidia starts to pull ahead and
especially in 4k
and nvidia is way ahead in the ray
tracing test that we do here
if you aren't high enrage pace and
performance and you have
a good amount of money to spend on a gpu
you're
you should be looking at nvidia and if
you want
high rasterization performance meaning
you're not planning to run
rt and you'd like to
play especially in 1080p 1440p you're
super competitive
uh maybe sponsored by a team or
something
then the 6900xt looks good but otherwise
most people you should look at the
6800xd and the 3080
and for more discussion on that check
out the 6800xt review that will have the
most up-to-date information
between the two the 3080 review is
before it came out so that's it for this
one thanks for watching subscribe for
more
we'll be trying to cover cyberpunk 2077
this week see how that goes
but that's the plan and uh timing wise
we're probably gonna be publishing some
older content like the
second part of our mac refurbishment
series from the side of the road
computer we
we got and uh probably a couple of other
things like old teardowns of 3080s that
were
odd we have one of those that we haven't
published yet so that'll be coming up
this week
subscribe for that go to store
camerasnexus.net to help us out directly
or patreon.comgamersnexus
and we'll see you all next time
[Music]
so